washington et les visuels on garde la
tête froide ici vous avez le sentiment
que ça peut déraper
ça pourrait même pas encore mais il ne
faudrait pas en tout cas ce serait
injuste et intolérable on n'a pas le
droit de pratiquer la haine sur toile
des innocents moi je ne crois pas en la
culpabilité collectif il n'y a pas de
coupable sauf ceux qui le sont et islam
du religion grandes religions
monothéistes
il faut le respecter je parle pas des
fanatiques qui ne respectent pas le
propre religion comme le christianisme
judaïsme il faut respecter les autres et
parfois nos traditions et le respect de
soi même donc absolument
il ne faut pas qu'on continue à harceler
les musulmans ou à les accueillir
non seulement les coupables sont
coupables